hey guys welcome to Jenkins pipeline
tutorial by simply learn my name is Chet
Annan and let me quickly walk you
through the topics that I planned to
cover as a part of this tutorial at a
very high level I'll be introducing you
chickens and then get into more details
of the continuous integration process as
most of you are aware most of the
software's in recent times are developed
using some or the other kind of agile
practices and continuous integration is
an important or key factor in all such
agile software development lifecycle
next I'll be looking at the software
delivery pipeline from a perspective of
if someone were to visualize all the
steps that is required from the time
someone gives out our requirement
software requirement it gets translated
into some sort of a code gets tested may
be moved into one of the testing
platforms and then migrated across or
moved across or propagated across
various environments and then finally
put out in production if one were to put
a value stream mapping for all this
steps that is involved each of these
steps could translate into a simple job
within Jenkins I will first look at what
existed in Jenkins or rather pre Jenkins
2.0 where we had a way of upstream
downstream mapping of jobs there was
some plugins that allowed us to
visualize all the jobs at one shot
starting from the first job that trigger
and then I will get into the most
powerful groovy scripting that are there
in Jenkins to rho0 outpost Jenkins 2.0
these groovy scripting uses much more
powerful ways of defining our pipelines
there are two different ways in which
you can write your scripts one is the
scripted one the other one is
declarative one there's very subtle
change or difference between each one of
them but these gives you a much more
flexible and much more powerful feature
to write complicated pipelines for your
software delivery having said that most
of these topics that I'm going to
discuss will be followed up with a demo
and the source code for most of these
would be on github repository alright
now as a prerequisite probably it may be
a good idea in case
if you haven't already watched please
watch our previous video wherein I
mentioned how to install Jenkins and how
to put up some sample jobs on our
Jenkins server so what exactly is
Jenkins Jenkins is nothing but a
powerful automation server that is
written in Java and it is a web
application which can also be run on any
web server but what makes Jenkins an
ideal choice for a continuous
integration server Jenkins has got
wonderful plugins that allows it to
connect to all kinds of our tools
software development deployment coding
build source code kind of a tools that
is what makes Jenkins very very powerful
from a continuous integration
perspective Jenkins can connect to
various source code or service and it
has also got plugins that allows it to
build deploy tests all kinds of software
artifacts so this is what makes Jenkins
an ideal choice for a continuous
integration server but mind you for me
Jenkins is nothing but a very very
powerful automated server at the heart
of it there's a lot of automation in it
but the powerfulness of Jenkins is more
so because of the tools that it
integrates with and the kind of plugins
that it has got what is continuous
integration from a software development
lifecycle assuming that the software
delivery is happening in very small
sprints maybe three to four weeks is
your delivery life cycle and there are a
bunch of developers who are located in
different locations who are working on
the same code base on the same branch
if the code chickens do not happen
quickly as in everyday if at all
developers stagger their code check-ins
into the repository finding problems at
a later stage would be very costly for
the whole project early direction of any
such issues would be you know quickly
resolved and would not affect your
delivery schedules so as a part of
continuous integration what is requested
or what is demanded is that every
developer checks in code pretty much you
know every day as long as it doesn't
break the core he checks in code pretty
much regularly and at the end of a day
you have an automated server which kind
of wakes up pulls the latest code
so this code has got the integrations of
all the code bases that has been checked
in by various developers so it pulls out
the code it builds on a completely
different server there is a CI server
which pulls this code it builds it it's
got all the tools that is required to
compile it build it and test it and
assuming that you got some good
percentage of test case automation
you're also having a most of your
regression test Suites automated if at
all there is a way by which in a couple
of hours time when the team is out or
rather team is slipping you have
verification that happens at a very
crucial level and then any breakages
even before the team arrives for the
next day if these are notified to the
whole team members saying an email going
out saying that something got broken
most of the code would be pretty okay
from the perspective of compilation
errors or a build errors it is the
functionality and the regression that
the team is worried about so if these
can be automated test it very very
quickly and very very fast and then any
breakages are detected early during the
day right by the time the next day
people come in they know what is broken
and possibly they know what code check
in broke that particular thing and they
can have a quick stand-up meeting and
then the discuss what broke the code and
able to fix it so this way any problem
that could possibly arise at a later
point of time if at all they kind of
moved to the initial phase of the
project any detection that is early
doesn't really hurt the team so this is
all continuous integration that is about
and Jenkins plays an important role in
being the continuous integration server
because it's got connections to anything
and everything all kinds of tools I mean
and then it is also got various ways on
which triggering the job which is a part
of its automation strategy now that we
know what is continuous integration and
where does Jenkins come into picture
let's look at the rest of the tasks of
our software development lifecycle so if
at all I were to visualize the kind of
steps that is involved in delivering my
software possibly the condensed
integration phase would be somewhere
here where multiple developers are
developing on that and then we have a
little bit of a stable code that is
there that can be kind of moved across
because I want to go ahead with the
particular build that I have and then I
want to migrate that I want to propagate
that across various environments so if
you consider the standard software
delivery approach in the first cycle you
just do some minimal testing and then
you kind of move that to one of the
environments and from there you kick off
more and more tests they could be
integration tests they could be
acceptance tests they could be
functionality check they could be a
stress test they could be a load test it
could be a system integration test all
kinds of tests that you can think about
and all the way may be propagating the
build across various environments if all
this can be considered as various steps
the fourth flow is such that as and when
the build moves across various phases if
there's any failure of course the build
propagation kind of stops everyone gets
notified but if at all everything goes
well so your workflow is progressing
well and at the end of the workflow you
eventually have a code which is pretty
much good to release now mind you I make
an assumption here that most of your
test cases are automated and you have a
good percentage of coverage of your test
cases but if that is not the scenario
then possibly there are some automated
tests or checks that may be required in
between but if the workflow can kind of
accommodate all that as well
you know you can visualize this as the
steps that is required for your software
development or a software delivery
lifecycle now in Jenkins the way this
kind of translate this is that each of
these tasks can be put out as a job so
now let me quickly I'll let you know or
let me quickly demo what existed in pre
Jenkins 2.0 where I could put up a
couple of jobs and I can connect them
using the upstream downstream linking
mechanism so if this job one if at all
it is a builder new in test cases if at
all that passes successfully job two
gets triggered if the job two is more
about running some more automated tests
or possibly deploying it to environment
and then kicking up some more test cases
that would be job - but if the
deployment fails or if some of the other
test cases fail it would not propagate
to the third shope all right so let me
quickly bring up my Jenkins instance and
put up some sample jobs and tell you how
to connect that or rather how would one
connect that using Jenkins 2.0 or three
it's 2.0 release I have now brought up
my Jenkins instance and in case some of
you don't know how to install Jenkins or
you don't know how to bring up your
Jenkins instance I would strongly
recommend that you watch our previous
videos on simple learn YouTube channel
where I've detailed out the steps that
is required for you to install Jenkins
and bring it up s'alright sub brought up
my Jenkins instance let me put up few of
those jobs now mind you I'm going to
cover the three Jenkins 2.0 feature here
alright so let me put up my first job
alright I hope I don't have that job I
say it's a freestyle project I don't
want to change anything I'm gonna put up
a very very simple job here it's in
batch command I say echo first job
triggered at right that's my first job
let me put up my second job freestyle
project alright that's my second job
got us very very simple echo statements
in this so just prints out the system
date and the time in it alright so I
could run these jobs individually if I
want so let me just check running my
third job so this is what I get and the
console output third job triggered at
date and time oops let me fix that right
that should fix it let me check my
second job
all right that's my second job all right
so I've got three jobs now if I were to
link them together or if at all I want a
scenario where after the first job is
successfully run
I would like to figure my second job so
I would do a small configuration change
in here I would say after this first job
is run
I want to trigger the second job so I
have something called as a post build
action so I can say that triggers some
other jobs from here so if you see this
publish record deploy all right trigger
trigger trigger trigger let me check the
other one build other projects this is
what I would want to do so after the
first job is done I want to trigger my
second job all right I would say save
this now let me go back to my second job
and then trigger the third job after the
second job is done
all right I would add this post build by
other projects third job again I'm not
really sure if you guys notice this
there is various configurations as to
when exactly do you want to trigger the
other job and the default one is to your
own leave the build stable so typically
this is the configuration that would
need we definitely don't want the third
job to be trigger in case the second job
fails all right so this is the
combination that I want or this is the
choice that I want and it saved this now
I have three of my jobs if you see this
the second job the upstream job is the
first job so let me check this kind of a
pipeline what I've said here is a very
very simple pipeline so after my first
job gets triggered if I build this guy
right the second job gets triggered
after the build first job is built so if
I click on the second job alright so the
first job was to get the second job and
after the second job it is triggering
the third job so this is how first job
second job and third Joubert kind of
linked but it's pretty hard to visualize
this as to you know if I need to see one
holistic picture where after the first
job after the second job after the third
job what does the flow it's not possible
for me to visualize that that's wherein
I install a plugin so let me go to
manage plugins right here I think I
already have it installed for those of
you don't have it installed you can go
to the available button I'm an available
tab and click on that the plugin is
called delivery pipeline plug-in I
already have it installed in case you
don't have it install it just go down
will you click on this and say install
without restart this is the plugin that
I want do to install alright so now we
have that plug-in installed so what I
want to do is after the plug-in is
installed you see something like this so
this is where I would create a new
visualization for the pipeline that I've
created so I would say my first pipeline
or I give a name for my visualization I
would say yes this upstream downstream
dependence is this is exactly what I
want and there's a bunch of settings
here I'll not look at any of that now
what I want is I just want to tell this
view that you know so I can give a name
for this I would give it as simply learn
pipeline and what's important is that I
specify what is the first job that
should be picked up as a part of this
pipeline and the final job is optional
because it knows that if the first job
is triggering this other jobs it knows
where to end this whole lifecycle so I
define a pipeline and you give a name
for my component and I initialize that
as my I mean I give it the first job so
I say ok and there you go this is much
better this gives you a beautiful
visualization of as to what happened
after the first job second job was run
second job if you click on any of these
that will in fact take me to that shop
all right there is also one other option
which is pretty good option in my
opinion which is about edit view yes
this is where it is and it will start
off a new pipeline will let me apply and
let me click OK on this what it gives me
is a way in which I can trigger my whole
pipeline from here so if I click on this
there you see the first job getting
trigger the second job is still running
the green means it's it's all run
properly and nicely second one is
triggered now the third one it's still
running all right so this is the
pipeline that existed prior to Jenkins
2.0 this is pretty decent enough and if
you see there's a one-to-one mapping but
if at all you remember we could go and
add multiple dependencies for the
projects that I set in just to give an
example let's have a go to my first job
I can do a configuration here and
nothing stops me from triggering
multiple jobs after this by giving the
comma I can trigger multiple jobs here
in case if I have to run few things
Baddeley this also gives me that option
to do that but having said that this was
the most primitive way in which the jobs
were kind of visualized and run
prior to Jenkins 2.0 now this feature
became such an important feature the
users wanted more and more complicated
because the pipelines was no not
complicated
it was not just one job after the other
they were multiple job that has to be
run and there was also an introduction
of the Jenkins agents where multiple
tasks could be parallel to run on
different agents so they wanted to Club
all of that and the pipeline could have
all the such complicated stuff that's
where in post Chunkin toward zero odd in
Jenkins 2.0 Jenkins are released a
version which has got the feature of
pipeline which can be written in groovy
scripts the groovy is funder full
scripting language it's very very
powerful
anybody can visualize your pipeline or
write your pipeline using programming
language and the point of everything is
code where this whole groovy script gets
into your source code repository so
instead of putting jobs here and in case
my Jenkins kind of fails you know
there's a crash on my Jenkins I don't
get back these jobs how do I bring back
all these jobs back so everything is
good that's the DevOps principle so the
pipeline's will be written as scripts
that is what I'm gonna do in my next
exercise in my previous example I showed
you the crude way in my opinion of
putting up a Jenkins pipeline but this
is what existed prior to Jenkins 2.0 and
now I have post Jenkins 2.0 in terms of
my ocean Jenkins motion is to rot 1:07
so this supports something called as a
scripted pipeline wherein you can write
your pipeline in terms of groovy scripts
no need to put up any jobs here and
remember how exactly you put up these
individual jobs you can write a pipeline
script in terms of groovy language let
me quickly show you a very very simple
and elementary pipeline that I have this
is what a groovy script would look like
pipeline any agent can run this stages
there are individual stages that is
defined as a subset of these stages so
the first stage is the compile stage and
stage has got some steps in it you can
have multiple steps in it and once only
after all these steps successfully
complete that's where in the stage gets
through perfectly with with the pass so
there's a compile a stage there's a
j-unit stage there's a quality gate
stage
there's a deploy stage and I'm really
not doing anything much within this
other than a coin you know some text
within each of these stages and what's
interesting is at the end there's
something called as a post which is
similar to our you can kind of equate
that to what would be there in a
try-catch kind of a block supposed
always meaning this would run all the
time
success only if at all all the steps
that were above in terms of the stages
they were completed successfully without
any failures so typically you would have
your email that is going out here saying
that the build is successful and stuff
like that failure if something went bad
if any of the step resulted in a failure
this particular block will get executed
unstable whenever any build is marked
unstable if at all only few things that
fail within your test run and you would
want to mark the build as unstable I've
changed this is an interesting option so
this compares the present run with the
previous run and if there's any change
meaning if the previous run was a
failure and the present run is a success
or vice versa
this would get triggered so this is what
a simple pipeline script would look like
so let me copy this pipeline and let me
put up a simple job for running this
pipeline so let me open up my Jenkins
say a new I would say scripted pipeline
yeah this is what I want I don't want to
choose a freestyle project this is going
to be a pipeline project so I would say
pipeline say okay alright this has got
far less options than the other jobs
that we put up so general I don't want
anything here I don't want any bill
trigger right so this is where I kind of
I can paste in whatever I had copied
there's also something called as a
pipeline syntax or syntax generator this
is like a lookup where you can choose
what you want to do and choose the
option that is specific to those steps
and you will get a pipeline generated or
a script generated for you Jenkins knows
that you're not very good at
understanding these pipelines so this
gives you this sandbox kind of an
environment where you can check out
whatever you want to do as a part of
your pipeline and then get the
equivalent groovy script from here let
me look at this in a bit later so for
now I have my pipeline syntax already
copied so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
paste when I copy
alright so this looks good okay I'm not
connecting to any native repository of
any of that I'm just running a very very
simple
which has got some steps in it and it
just compiles or rather it just puts out
some messages saying that this ditch
completed successfully
and stuff like that so let me save this
and let me try to run this scripted
pipeline all right if you see this
you'll see each of those steps going
through and if at all I look at the
console output compiled successfully
unit passed all the stages passed there
was a pass the failures doesn't show up
you will see the messages from our post
or the try-catch block that I was
mentioning earlier so this is how one
would put up a pipeline and you also get
to see the visualized view of your
pipeline that says which stage run after
which phase how much time did it take
and he can click on any of these and get
into looking at the logs from that
particular pipeline front that was
pretty easy wasn't it now let me give
you another scenario for a pipeline
where in the source code of my pipeline
would be in a github repository and I
will write scripts to grab this
particular code and run some part of the
code which is there there's a part of
the repository so let me look at the
repository that I have I have a
repository out here on the simply long
github account which is called the
pipeline script and if you see in there
there are a bunch of batch files that
are there so the first batch file would
be a buried batch so there's nothing in
it except that it is just trying to
build a particular project you can
visualize this as individual batch files
which actually contain the scripts for
building running deploying and checking
the quality gate of your particular
project so I have a couple of batch
files that is here and this is on the
github repository so I would need to
write Jenkins job which will login to my
github account and then check out this
particular repository from my account
and then run these batch files as a part
of those individual steps within within
the scripted pipeline so let me check as
to how I could do that
let me put up a new project for this let
me call this scripted pipeline scripted
pipeline from github
alright so let this be a pipeline
project that's good enough for me
let me see my scripts all right now this
is where I need
to put in the scripts for pulling out
the code repository from my github
server and running those batch files
that are there as a part of the
repository so what I want to do is I
already have the skeleton of my pipeline
that is written which is very similar to
whatever was the pipeline syntax that I
showed you in the previous step so I
just copy this out here and then paste
it here so what I have here is I've
written or the high-level skeleton
without really putting in the actual
steps required for checking out rather
or rather running those build scripts so
I've got four steps one is the git
checkout step in the build step unit
test quality gate and possibly the
deploy all right so I need to put in the
actual scripts that is required for
first checking out the repository from
my github thermal so this is where I
will make use of this pipeline syntax so
as I mentioned earlier you have a bunch
of help that is available for you to
figure out the actual scripts that is
required for you to write within your
spy plane so what I wanted to do is
check out something from gates so it's
get related so search on git and you'll
find this option so I got a specify my
git repository URL and my credentials so
let me look at the repository URL this
would be my repository URL so let me
copy this I'm gonna copy the HTTP URL of
my repository and branch is good and one
thing that you got to notice is for now
the repository is anyway a public
repository on github so even though if I
don't specify any credentials that work
for me still but in case you have a
repository which needs strictly a
username and password to be specified
you can kind of pad it out here using
add jankins and you can give your user
name and password out here but for now I
don't need any of these things so I'm
gonna just say git checkout or rather
the URL of my repository and what we
want is the master branch for now I have
only one branch on my get up server so
this is good for me so this is what
exactly I want to do as a part of the
script so if I click this this is the
script that I need to put in my build
script so I come over here and this is
what will check out the core from my
repository all right so now once I get
my core on
repository from my repository rather it
will grab those call all these batch
files and get it on to my Jenkins
workspace now I allowed to run these
batch files as a part of each of my step
so let me look at what will be the
syntax so the first one that I want to
run would be my bail dot bat all right
so I want to run a batch file all right
and what is the name of the batch file
that I want run I want to run this build
out back so generate pipeline script
this is all that I got to specify as a
part of my build step and then unit
tests
I have just change this to unit I think
that's what I have in my repository okay
that is unit and then deploy and quality
she'll capital quality and this one
would be deploy all right so this piece
of code will actually get into my
repository and check out my source code
and grab it and take it to the Jenkins
workspace so from this workspace since
all the files are there in the root
directory of this workspace
it will run these batch files one after
the other all right let me save this and
let me try to run my pipeline alright so
it runs a lot of things in the
background trying to get the source code
from my repository whoa that was fast
all right so it pulled out all the
source code from my repository the last
commit message from where the source
code was pulled out there was this
create deploy not bad that looks good
I'm saying building checked out project
building the checked out project this is
what I had in my Billy dot pad if I'm
not mistaken okay building the project
that's just what is there with the time
stamp running unit test cases unit dot
bat it is running unit dot bat and then
giving me the date end times time okay
so all these kind of paths and if I go
back to the project I will also see this
beautiful view of how exactly what is
the time that was taken for checking out
the repository running the build on bat
running the unit test cases quality
gates and all this isn't that pretty
simple now let me modify my previous job
or rather let me
a new job for making use of an agent
Farren I could delegate a job to an age
in typically agents can be brought up on
any other remote machines other than
where your primary agent conserver is
running in case you don't know or you
don't know how to start up this agents I
would strongly recommend that you refer
to our previous Jenkins video on the
simply learn youtube channel alright so
let me just check the status of my agent
for now
yes he's offline so let me start this
agent because agent is not running so I
have the agent set up in my sequel on
agents so let me copy the script file
that is required for starting my agent
let me go to the agents folder open up a
command prompt and let me try to bring
up my agent right so the agent is up and
running for now I don't have the luxury
of starting my agent on a different
machine so my agent is running on my
mercy machine but the agent workspace is
C : agent while my primary agent can
server is running has the workspace out
your C colon program files 86 and this
is the workspace of my Jenkins alright I
hope you can kind of differentiate those
two alright so now what I want is I look
at the same job that I'd put in earlier
or rather modify that let the steps be
the same but I don't want to run that on
my master server let me try to delegate
that using the script so let me put up
an agent script a job right it will be a
pipeline job say ok and let me copy this
was a step that I had put in for my
previous job so agent any so what I'm
gonna do now is I don't want this to be
running on any other agent I want this
to be running on the agent who's labeled
is let me check what is the labels of my
agent that is running okay so this is
the name of my agent okay Windows not so
let me just copy that there alright so
with a very subtle change instead of
saying agent any I'm going to run
or rather I'm gonna specify the agent
would be running this job is the one was
got the label as Windows not so this
agent that I brought on my system has
got the name as Windows known and it is
configured to pick up any job that
matches the label to which any job is
kind of delegated so let me come back to
my jobs well is my scripted agent job
I've got too many jobs running all right
so this is my agent scripted job that I
left half way through so here in the
pipeline what I'm gonna do is yes this
is all I'm gonna need
so the job remains the same git checkout
is gonna check out from same repository
run the batch files accordingly but this
change is just to ensure that this job
is kind of delegated on the agent
alright so this would be my agent job
let me save this let me get back to the
dashboard and let me run it from here if
we see this you know the master and
agent are both idle as of now let me try
to run this agent scripted shop alright
so the agent kind of kicked in and there
was a job that was delegated to the
agent if I look at what is there in the
console output he's pretty much doing
whatever was there as a part of the job
but the interesting thing to notice that
this is the new workspace rather this is
delegated to the agent and the agents
workspace is this particular folder so
this is where it's gonna get all this
stuff run the whole thing and you know
the flow is pretty much the same the
only thing is this whole thing ran on
the agent if I need to check my agent I
would see the workspace out here agent
scripted job if you look at this all the
batch files are here and this is where
the job was kind of delegated to run so
with a very subtle change in in the
scripting I can ensure that the jobs are
kind of delegated on to the agent the
pipeline job specifically as I mentioned
earlier Jenkins provides you two
different ways of writing pipelines
called the scripted and the declarative
the first one that was launched was the
scripted pipeline this is heavily based
on groovy scripting since Jenkins ships
along with the groovy engine so this was
the first script or the first support
for pipeline that was provided by
Jenkins in 2.0 this needs a little bit
of a learning curve
since our groovy is a wonderful script
understanding that may be a little
cumbersome but then once you kind of
master it you can write really powerful
scripts based on groovy at a very high
level this is what a typical scripted
pipeline would look like something
called as a note node represents the
agent or the actual box on which the ERV
trouble be running and then a bunch of
stages are put out which each of the
stage along with the steps that needs to
be covered as the part of those stages
listed one below the other
so all these stages if they run
peacefully then the whole task is kind
of marked as run successfully since
understanding groovy or learning groovy
was a little tough for many of the
people so this is a new one from Jenkins
where and it provides you a much simple
and friendly syntax for writing
pipelines
without really needing to understand or
without merely reading to learn some
groovy scripting again there's a very
subtle chain between these and you there
are a lot of lookups for figuring out
what is a better pipeline for you to
kind of write but if you can figure out
the difference or if you can try to find
that particular piece of code which kind
of helps you out with your pipeline
either of the scripts there's not really
any difference in writing or kind of
delivering your pipeline using either of
these two methods
alright so declared pipeline is
something like this where you have an
agent you can specify the agent label or
if you can say agent any it will pick up
whatever is an available agent and run
the job and then you have something
called as stages stages is nothing but a
collection of stage and stage could have
multiple steps so defined within this so
if any of the steps in any of the stage
fails then that particular complete
stage and the build is marked as failure
so very subtle difference between both
these two syntax but using either of
these you can write powerful scripts for
your pipeline now let me come up with an
example where I'm going to at least demo
one of the feature where you could run a
master and a slave job in parallel so
let me come up with a demo for that
particular scenario
let me put up a new job for my
isn't pipeline let me call this and this
would be a pipeline project I don't want
anything here let me look at the
pipeline script that I have pipeline
agent none stages and there's a first
stage where this would be a kind of non
parallel stage where there's a need for
you to possibly pull out the source code
from one of the repositories and
possibly unit test it if all the unit
test cases pass then possibly you want
to deploy it to one of the test
environments that would be what will be
there as a part of a non parallel stage
and then you may have a bunch of tests
that could be run and assuming that you
know you have a Windows node you have a
Linux node you have some other kind of
an operating system based known you
could run these stages in parallel so
forth just for demonstration I've just
put in two parallel stages in parallel
is the keyword that you're gonna use for
running just paddling so I would say
parallel stage test on Windows and I'm
gonna run this in my Windows node well I
could run a bunch of steps that have
want out here and then in the other
stage or other step what I want is I
will run something else on my master as
long as this parallel keyword is
encountered Jenkins will ensure that
these two stages are run parallel II for
now I have both these things running on
the same machine but assuming that these
were running on different boxes you
could kind of visualize it as these two
steps are gonna be started paralleling
without really any dependency on each
other and then you could wait for the
test results and then based upon whether
both of these steps passed or failed
with one of them failed then we could
kind of mark the build accordingly so
let me copy this pretty pretty simple
script let me put this out here and now
let me save this out and I can try to
pull this all right there you go
the stage will be executed first this is
a non perilous day that's gonna happen
then the task one non agent task one one
master followed by as I said since I
have only one node or rather one system
one with both these things are running
simultaneously you not really see a
benefit of this but assuming that you
have a couple of boxes on which you have
multiple agents running you possibly
want to run your selenium tests on the
windows box because selenium brings up
some of those UI which needs
Roza he could possibly need some
regression test that could run on Linux
boxes or Linux agents and then you can
kind of break down your tasks into
multiple things that is running on
multiple systems at the same time and
then collate all the results okay one
final thing all right now I have all my
particular job or rather the steps
required for my pipeline put down in
terms of the scripts and this is saved
in this particular job that's not a good
or a recommended approach so what I'll
do is I'll copy all of these steps out
here and then what needs to be done is
actually let's say let me go back to
this repository the most preferred
approach is where you create something
called as a jenkins file jenkins
file and you paste all the scripts that
is required for your pipeline now this
is in a true sense the DevOps approach
where I'm gonna save this out so if at
all you have a pipeline defined for your
project the best place to kind of put
out your configurations for the pipeline
is within your repository so this may be
a different project that I was referring
to but assuming that you have your
project where you know you have to
define your pipeline instead of putting
that as a particular job on Jenkins and
fearing that if Jenkins fails other jobs
there's a crash and then you lose out
your job configuration the best approach
is to use a Jenkins file put all the
steps that is required the tried tested
steps that is required as a part of your
Jenkins file and then you can put out a
job that can pull the source code from
here as well as use the steps that is
defined in the jet gains file so let me
end up by putting up another job which
is a true job's kind of a job so I would
say DevOps pipeline and this is a
pipeline script and then I'm not gonna
say any of these things I would say the
pipeline script is from the source code
management so my pipeline script is
already defined it is present in a same
so what is my SVA and I mean what is my
source code repository this is my source
code repository where I already have
this so let me copy this URL this is my
URL I don't need any credentials because
the proposal is an event public
repository
that is all that is required I would say
and the scripted file it automatically
picks up Jenkins file alright so let me
save this let me open this so that's the
beauty of DevOps wherein I have a
pipeline that is defined and instead of
putting the pipeline as a job because
pipeline is nothing but a configuration
the configuration is also checked into
the source code repository and any
changes to this pipeline instead of
putting that modifications in the job
these are all captured as a part of my
repository so the changes are nicely
configured so that you know we know
who's done what change that concludes
our tutorial on Jenkins pipelines and I
hope you enjoyed watching this video for
more such learnings keep watching our
simply learn youtube channel thank you
so much and have a great day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here